voters across Denmark turned out in big
numbers as soon as polling stations
opened these are tough times for the
Danes Rising living costs and climate
change worries have become a daily
concern
I'm not for a country where few have too
much while many have too little I want
equality this leads to crime and
violence in the society
I'm worried about the high energy prices
money is losing its value and we don't
know how do we get through this crisis
prime minister and social Democrats
leader Matthew Frederickson is confident
her party will remain the biggest Block
in Parliament but the far right is
gaining ground we have had some
different discussions about inflation
and and prices and the energy crisis is
I will say on the on the top of the
agenda of the majority of the days this
is the man who is likely to end a
decades-long tradition of politics
dominated by left and right coalitions
former prime minister last look
erasmussen presents himself as a
moderate alternative to meta production
his Rivals accuse him of stealing votes
from the traditional right where he
originally comes from the idea is to
create a new political situation you
know we are challenged by
demographic where China's by
the economic crisis
I'm a True Believer and supporter of the
Scandinavian welfare model but it's
indeed challenged
the next government isn't expected to
change the country's cause on
immigration that's because in that bit
to stem the rise of the far right the
left and Center parties have taken a
hard line on migrants and refugees
the social Democrats are likely to
remain Denmark's biggest political party
but meta frederickson's chances of
staying in power May ultimately depend
on whether the moderates will want to
form a coalition with her and if they do
they expect to have a bigger say in her
government Copenhagen